DON'T AGREE WITH.
IT WILL AFFECT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE WILL GET IT AT 10:00 A.M.
TOMORROW MORNING.
>> Bret: ANOTHER BIG DAY.
THANKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INITIAL
REACTION TO THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT DECISION TODAY ON
TWITTER.
ONE WORD, WOW.
HE HAD MUCH MORE TO SAY LATER.
>> TODAY'S SUPREME COURT RULING
JUST COMING OUT, A TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS, A TREMENDOUS VICTORY
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FOR
OUR CONSTITUTION.
>> IN THE CABINET ROOM WITH
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
PRAISE FOR THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION ON HIS TRAVEL BAN.
>> WE HAVE TO BE TOUGH AND WE
HAVE TO BE SAFE AND WE HAVE TO
BE SECURE.
AT A MINIMUM, WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE THAT PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW WHO'S COMING IN, WE KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM.
DISAGREED WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
THE MAJORITY OPINION.
IN A STATEMENT,
SENATOR DICK DURBIN SAYING
HISTORY WILL NOT BE KIND TO THIS
PRESIDENT'S POLICIES OR THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES WHO LENT
THEIR NAMES TO THIS TROUBLING
ROLLING.
THE SUPREME SENT THE CASE BACK
TO THE LOWER COURTS FOR FURTHER
PROCEEDINGS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONSIDERS THE MATTER SETTLED.
>> YOU GOT THE FINAL WORDS ARE?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY MUCH A
FINAL WORD.
THE SUPREME COURT.
WE WIN IT, WE LOSE IT, WE JUST
WAITED FOR THE SUPREME COURT.
THAT'S THE FINAL WORD.
PRESIDENT'S SALES.
HE HAS BEEN BATTERED BY A PUBLIC
OUTCRY OVER THE SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES AT THE BORDER.
HIS AIDES HOUNDED AT RESTAURANTS
AND THEIR HOMES.
TODAY HE DOUBLED DOWN IN HIS
CALLS FOR CONGRESS TO GIVE HIM
WHAT HE WANTS TO SECURE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WE HAVE TO CHANGE IT, IT'S SO
SIMPLE.
IT'S CALLED I'M SORRY, YOU CAN'T
COME IN.
YOU HAVE TO GO IN THROUGH A
LEGAL PROCESS.
A JUDGE WHERE THE JUDGE IS GOING
TO TAKE THREE YEARS BEFORE YOU
CAN COME BACK.
IN THE MEANTIME YOU NEVER COME
BACK BECAUSE YOU ARE ALREADY IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> AS HE KEEPS UP THE PRESSURE
ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO TOOK AIM
TODAY AT AN AMERICAN ICON.
A YEAR AGO HE WAS PRAISING
HARLEY DAVIDSON FOR BUILDING ITS
BIKES IN THE USA.
TODAY HE RIPPED THEM FOR PLANS
TO SHIP SOME PRODUCTION TO
THAILAND.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING A HARLEY
DAVIDSON SHOULD NEVER BE BUILT
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY, NEVER.
IF THEY MOVE, WATCH, IT WILL BE
THE BEGINNING OF THE END.
THEY'VE SURRENDERED, THEY QUIT.
THE AURA WILL BE GONE AND THEY
WILL BE TAXED LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
HARLEY-DAVIDSON SAYS IT WAS THE
THREAT OF RETALIATION TO THE
PRESIDENT'S TRADE TARIFFS THAT
EFFECTIVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTED IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH TARIFFS.
>> THEY ANNOUNCED IT EARLIER
THIS YEAR SO HARLEY-DAVIDSON IS
USING THAT AS AN EXCUSE AND I
DON'T LIKE THAT.
I'VE BEEN VERY GOOD TO THEM AND
>> SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
PAUL RYAN WHO SHARES A HOME
STATE WITH HARLEY-DAVIDSON SAYS
HE IS NO FAN OF TARIFFS.
>> ON IMMIGRATION, WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS TOLD ME THEY EXPECTED
THE MEASURE THAT SHOULD BE
BEFORE THE HOUSE TOMORROW LIKELY
WON'T GO ANYWHERE SO THE NEXT
MOVE WOULD LIKELY BE A NARROWLY
TAILORED BILL TO SUPERSEDE THE
1997 COURT SETTLEMENT THAT ONLY
ALLOWS CHILDREN TO BE HELD IN
DETENTION WITH THEIR PARENTS FOR
PERIOD OF 20 DAYS.
OFFICIALS SAY IT'S FAR LESS THAN
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ASKING FOR, BUT A LOT BETTER
THAN WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF DHS AND